[Music]
hello i'm scottie meyer and you are
watching i've got a question and today's
question actually came in a written form
so uh i really appreciate you guys
reaching out to us and asking us
questions you're being impacted by our
content and we welcome that so
today's i've got a question says i'm an
artist an actor and i like stories and
if i'm going to make a fantasy tv series
i want to make it sure that this stuff
is out as on point as possible i need to
shape the story around the bible not the
other way around
so here is my question what is some of
the things that i should consider when
producing a piece of media or a piece of
art
what are the most important things to
consider when making a show that
parallels the great controversy or the
bible now when we talk about the great
controversy that's really the war
between christ and satan and which one's
going to win you know i
i used to look at art as something that
was just fun and the more that i really
dove into
filmmaking and understanding what does
it mean to be an artist i i started
recognizing that all art is meant to
influence somebody
and nobody makes a piece of art and uh
doesn't want anybody to be affected by
it so once i kind of understood it from
that perspective i began to kind of look
at everything that i was actually making
i went to film school and
learned how to make movies uh but
when i looked at the types of things
that i was actually working on
it really didn't do humanity much good
in fact the things that i was
highlighting were a lot of terrible
things in society and terrible things in
life so i came back into a relationship
with god and i was still an artist still
wanted to make creative projects and so
i began to say okay well whatever i'm
doing how do i want people what do i
want people to walk away with and that
really changed my focus and my
perspective and how i was going about
each creative process so at this point
in my life i am very interested in
making art that influences people just
to consider a relationship with god or
to highlight the beauty of the things
that god has created
so here's a couple pieces of advice for
you
i don't think necessarily everything has
to say jesus or have all this
christianity terms in it but i think it
should be in line with your bible
so what are some of the concepts that
would be in line with the bible i don't
necessarily believe that every single
thing has to say jesus this or
christianity that but i think for the
most part
what is that person walking away from
your art piece with
now if they're walking away with the
inspiration of man i really want to be a
better person in my life or i want to
you know i should do more
to treat people nicer or or something
like that then it would be in line with
your bible
and it would speak according to the way
that the bible would speak but it
doesn't i don't believe necessarily have
to have
that exact verbiage it can be a metaphor
or a parallel so obviously the closer
that you understand the bible or you
study the bible the more you can
incorporate those ideas into your piece
of art so that's what i would suggest
i'm not scared of creativity or
or even even a story that would be a
allegory as long as your end goal is
really having people walk away with
something
that points them closer to god if the
bible speaks against certain things such
as magic and sorcery and uh c.s lewis is
a great example for this because i
believe that he
used a lot of magic and sorcery and sort
of the chronicles of nia beginning and
the bible speaks actually not to use
those kind of things so how do we
rectify that i think it would be safe to
say that if the bible says don't do this
don't add that into your your art piece
or your project um
and that doesn't mean that you can't
tell a story that actually has something
to do with magic and sorcery the bible
has stories in there where people dealt
with magic and sorcery but the end goal
was here's what happens when people get
involved in this
and that i believe is an okay use of
that type of a thing as long as you're
not using those elements and promoting
it as this could be a good thing
i will give you this piece of advice
pray about it ask god if this is the
type of way he wants you to use your
creativity and you'll be surprised he
will answer you if you ask him
one thing you might think about while
getting involved with other creatives
i i like collaborating with lots of
different people i think everybody
is is got a talent and a skill and
filmmaking is often like
making music you have different people
that can play just different instruments
and as you come together you can make
something beautiful if you're really
wanting to make something that is very
specifically and specially spiritually
orientated
be careful
to
know who you're getting involved with
and if you really are
making an allegory for for something
that you believe in
just make sure everybody is on the same
page because you can really start adding
people to your creative process that can
really steer your your yourself in in a
different direction and it may sometimes
take you in a in a direction you didn't
want to go so once again i believe that
you should pray about each and every
person that gets involved with that
project and and really just openly uh
tell everybody what it is that you're
wanting to achieve with this project and
make sure that they are all in agreeance
of that same direction do you remember
the story in matthew 5 when jesus told
the story about the salt he said you are
the salt of the earth but if the salt
loses its saltiness what is it good for
it's to be thrown out and trampled upon
the feet see i believe as a christian
and as a believer in god you are the
salt of the earth you are the one that
makes life more flavorful makes it make
sense and if you don't do that for other
people and you make it more confusing i
believe that's like what jesus was
saying with it's losing its saltiness
it's losing its ability to enhance the
flavor
and i believe like first corinthians 10
31 says
everything that you do you should do to
the glory of god
[Music]
thanks again for watching i've got a
question and remember
if you've got something that you want us
to answer you have a variety of ways
that you can get to us you can find us
on social media you can comment on this
video in youtube or you can directly
email us your question or send it to us
in the mail and we thank you guys for
watching
[Music]
you